mouton noir s'est dit quelque chose
c'est le nom d'une course personne n'a
jamais vu je croyais que c'était légende
urbaine
mon père adoré cette voiture
le vainqueur à flot toute l'année
et qui lui lui c'est un gars que je
voulais présenter
tu vois il a participé à la dernière
course
mais ça ça suffit pas pour faire partie
de l'équipe tient
à partir d'aujourd'hui ton surnom c'est
le cas ce
soir
nous voilà dans l'univers d'ubu
je fais toujours ce qu'il chante toi
j'ai perdu assez d'argent aujourd'hui la
fête ne fait que commencer
la clope au bec c'est qu'il leur chef
tandis qu'il a arraché son propre cordon
ombilical avant que l'échappée de
l'utérus de sa mère sacré personnage il
m'a menacé mort bout de phrase
celui qui remportera le tournoi
décrochera le titre de diablo pas de
frais d'entrée l'an prochain il
empochera environ dans l'es5 fourni
c'est votre intégrité physique qui est
en jeu
tout le monde a besoin d'argent que le
monde n'est pas prêt à mourir pour
gagner et a dit que j'allais mourir et y
ferez quoi du fric ma soeur est très
malade à elle de se faire opérer à
l'étranger il nous faut du fric c'est
dommage que je puisse être avec toi
bientôt on ira à vienne et la balle pour
en soigner font attention à brest ont
pris mon père a toujours détesté perdre
faiveley
côté sport
ces deux gaffes independent m